まあ一応結論はそれなんです
かっこいい人間にはなりたいんだけど
このかっこよささ どこで評価するのかというと
この腐る肉体で人を評価するんじゃないんですよ
あの人の肌の色がなんかみずみずしくて可愛いとかね
何日ですかね それが それからしわが出ますからね
かなり痩せてすごいかっこいいんだと
何日ですかね いくらかっこよくたっても中年になってくるとどうしても中年太りになります
それでも頑張っちゃうと
もうもう生きてる死体みたい
ガリガリで やっぱり中年になってくると
それいくらかは脂肪はもうあっちこっちで溜まるんで
それはもう避けられません
溜まらないようにしちゃうと
ものすごく逆に不健康になっちゃうんです
そううまくはいきません
だから体力あるんだとかね
あれこれやと そんなもんで人を評価するんじゃないんです
輝く心で人を評価するんです
心にはしわが出ませんし
年も取りませんしね これはずっともう続けちゃいもんだからね
変化しながら まあ結論が出ましたから
もう大丈夫です もう途中で消えたってのは
まあ人間のね 美しい体とスタイルということは
まあ私たちは一般的にはこれはもうかっこいいと思いますね
見ただけですぐもう惹かれてしまいます
美しい体は生まれる時ついてくるから
そうでない人は自己嫌悪に陥るしかありません
しかし 体形っていうのは
まあ生まれる時もう出来上がっているんだからね
美しい かっこいい人 スタイルのいい人がかっこいいと言っちゃうと
これはすごい差別なんです
そう思うことの罪なんです
なぜならば どんな体で生まれるかと知ったものじゃないでしょうに
いろいろ体があるんだから
その中で一部だけすごいかっこよくて
ああ 羨ましいと思っちゃうと
他の人のことをどう思いますかね
当然差別してるでしょ
なんとは不細工だ かっこ悪いんだとか
人に向かってそんなことを言ったら
その人の心はどうなってるんですかね
形はどうであろうとも
平等で見ることが 人のことを平等に見ることこそが立派な人格者の生き方なんです
だから もし社会がスタイルが良くて
日本のテレビと映画なんか出てくる若い男たち
女たちみたいにね もう
そういうスタイルのほうがよろしいかと
他の人々はあまりよくないんだと思っちゃうと
これも差別ですね 苦労して体の形を変えることも不可能ではありませんが
それも皆にできることではありません
まあいろいろ苦労したら体変えることは現代技術ではできますけどね
まあ整形技術っていうのはありますからね
鼻を伸ばしてもらったりとかね
あごを削ってもらったりとかね
いろいろそれでいいんでしょうかね
本当に 胸を大きくしてもらったりとか
大丈夫だと思いますかね
体の中にシリコンとかを埋め込んで
病気の場合はどうしようもないんです
それ以外はただ世間にかっこよく見せるためにだけ
なんで人間そういう風に体をいじるんでしょうかというと
世界が悪いんですよ 差別するんだからね
ちょっとスタイルプロポーションのスタイルがちょこちょこと違う女の子たちは
みんなにあんまりもう差別されますから
やっぱり苦労して お金
借金まででもして 命までかけてもう整形技術手術をしたりする
だからどこまで残酷なことをするのかと
体いじるのはいいわけじゃないんで
どう考えても病気以外は
だから社会がそうやって差別意識で
人を軽視するんだから
もう被害者がいっぱい出たりする
まあそれもできる人もできない人もいますからね
またお金がなかったらまたできないし
ただ安いお金それほど取らないんだからといって
もうどこかヤブ医者のところに行ったところで
実は失敗するともうどうにも元にも戻れなくなっちゃうしね
まあいろいろありますよ
しかし 体形は止まるものではありません
しかし 覚えておきましょう
体っていうのは止まるものじゃないんです
ずっと変化していくんです
だから少々スタイル変えたんだからといって
それでも体が止まらないんです
変化するんです まさか削った顎がまた骨がついたらどうしますかね
こういう DNA のプログラムだからね
もう太ってるんだからと体の中
あれいろんな脂肪やらあれこれ取り出してもう痩せたように見せても
その人がどうせ脂肪溜まる DNA だったらどうしますかね
だから体っていうのは生き物だから
ずっと変化するんですよ
だから美しい形があるんだからといって
それで人を評価しても意味がない
これはあるある 短い時間だけのことでのことだから
変化するんですね もう絶えず変化していく
それに対応するのも大変ですよ
だからまあ大体ね 我々は体重を保つことで
もうスタイルを保つことでも大変苦労していますよ
ちょっとうっかりしちゃうと
もうまた元に戻ったりとかね
まあ元に戻るということではないんだけど
まあ一応またせっかく保っている形が崩れてはいきます
ですから もう体のスタイルを保つことも大変です
だからそこで我々理解してほしいことは
体っていうのは壊れるんだよと
そんないいんじゃないか
別にどうせ壊れるんだからという
この肉体至上主義は捨てた方がいいんです
この世界は壊れてもうものひどい目にあっているのは
世界みんな肉体至上主義なんですね
肉体だけだと思っているんです
この他宗教で魂のことを言うんだけど
調べてください ただの肉体のことを言ってるんです
この肉体を持ってこの世の中で楽しく生きているでしょうね
それがレベルアップして天国で楽しめるんそう楽しめるんだよと言ってる話です
調べたら まあ今も一つ
一番私は調べていますけどね
まあ全部そういう話で
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
パッサチッタカタンビンバンアルカーヤンサモッシタンアータランバフサンカッパンヤッサナッティドゥアンティティ
で まあこれはあの翔太
何さん 正田大観さんの訳で
私はそんな立派な日本語は書けません
何でしたっけ？身を様々に作りなされた欲のこれ言語
幻影 幻影をを寄せ集めの傷だらけの体を病んだ妄想大きいものをそこにこれ何でした？常光で留まり住むものは何であれ存在しないという
意味はわかりますかね
私にはちょっとわかりにくいんですけど
日本語はちょっと難しくて
まあ見よ パッサっていうのは
これ見よ それはいい 見てみようと
この体は知ったかたん
ビンバン ビンバンっていうのはイメージ
もう作り上げたイメージだよと
これがいろいろ塗ったり
いろんなことをつけたりしてね
ほら見よと この体はと
あらゆるいろんなことで
もう作り立ててるんじゃないかと
こちら このイメージということは
このビンバンというのは幻影で訳していますけどね
まあそれは正しいんですけど
まあ我々は幻のように体は見せているんですね
お釈迦様がニコってほら
見よ この体は幻見せかけやと
これが本当のところは
アルカーヤン アルカーヤンというのは
もしかすると私は意味を書いていると思います
アルカーヤンというのは
体からずっともういろんな不浄の液体があっちこっち体中出ているんですよ
体中から漏れているんですよ
いろんなもう汚い不浄な液体が
だから出来物と同じなんです
こんな体がなんか見せかけたってもね
本当のところそうじゃないでしょうと
頭の上から足の裏まですーっといろんなものはもう出るわ出るわ出るわ出るわ
それ溜まっちゃうともう臭くてもうたまらないでしょう
そういう体を見なさいと
アートラン アートランというのは病気っていうこと
でも体っていうのはもう病気そのものなんです
お釈迦様は病気っていうのは
例えばお腹が空くことも
病気 喉が渇くことも病気
なぜ病気っていうのは手当てしなかったら死ぬんです
壊れるんです 体っていうのはすーっと手当てしないと
そのまんま保つことはできない
そのままでもそれでも保つことはできないんです
しかし 我々はもうすぐ壊れるんだから
ご飯をあげたり 水をあげたり
いろんなことをしたりして
ずーっと手当をやっているんです
しかし これ 慢性的な病気で治るということはないんです
なのにバフサンカッパン
またもう えっと これは訳はね
これいろいろありますけど
こちらは妄想気と書いてますから
まあそれにしましょう
まああれこれやと もう妄想ばっかりやってる
ものすごい臭い 不浄な肉体なんです
中身だっても妄想ばっかりで
それまた臭いんですね
やっさなってドゥアンティティ
この体っていうのは常光で変わることなく
あ なんて言いますか この何か銅像みたいにあっちこっちありますね
美術作品 そんな感じでいつ見たっても美しくあるわけじゃありません
そういう体が我々をすごく欲しいと思っちゃうんですよ
この腐ってるこのものが
ああ 欲しい欲しいって何考えてるのか
体触ることもできないほど汚い液体がもうもう漏れているのに
自分の体も欲しがるし
他人の体も欲しがったりする
しかし 何の実体もないんだと
また他のお釈迦様の言葉
パリジンナミダンローパンローガニッダンパバングランビッジャティプーティサンデーホマラナンタンヒジイヴィタン
これも翔太さんの訳で追い朽ちた
この形態体は病の巣となり
壊れ崩れるものとして存している
腐敗の憎み 何でしたっけ？肉親は朽ち果てる
死という終局ですかね
終局あるのがまさに生命である
この訳で 私はこれだけは立派に訳していると思いますけど
最後の行はね これなかなか日本訳にならないところなんですね
パリジンナミダンローパン
この体はね まあ壊れて壊れていくんだよと
老害に病 もう体の中はまあ病の巣だよと
パバングラン壊れるんだと
ビジャティ壊れること
プーティサンデーホっていうのはもういろんなもの出るという汚いもの
マラナンタンヒジービタン
命っていうのは死で終わるものであると
生きてるならば まあ死ということは確実にあるんだよと
そういうことで 仏教では決して肉体がこの臭い壊れる病気の巣である
この体は評価の基準にはしません
見ようともしない どうでもいいんです
足が 1本あっても  1本ついて四便があっても
全然どうでもいいんです
目が一つ見えなくても
あるいは目が目がもう 3個目玉がついていても
あまり気にはしません
形は だからかっこいい人間だったら
まず我々は学ばなくちゃいけないこと
この肉体を全く気にしないことなんです
肉体の形で人のことをわからないんです
騙されるんですよ みんなもうなんとなく見た目が良ければ
もうすぐもうそこでもう優しくなっちゃうんですね
それではもう本当に騙されます
だから訪問販売の場合はね
ものすごいかっこいい男たちを選ぶんだからね
若者で また結構高価なネクタイぐらいはつけてあげて
もう出しますからね いかに人を馬鹿にしているのかと
次の問題は かっこいいと我々思うのはこの財産ですね
じゃあ大富豪はかっこいいものかと
財産があること 家族がいることは人の自慢ではあるが
仏教はその裏を見るんですね
プッターマッティダナンマッティイティバローヴィハンヤティアッターヒアッタノーナッティクトープットークトーダナ
で 私の訳じゃないんです
で 私には子たちが存在する
私には財が存在すると
愚者は所有の思いに打ちのめされる
まさに自己は自己のものとして存在しないと言ったってわからないんですね
だから思いのままにならない存在であるということですね
意味はどうして子たちが自己のものとして存在するであろう
どうして財が自己のものとして存在するであろう
すごいわかりやすいことで
自分の体も心も自分のままにならないんですよ
できればやってみてということは
自分の意のままに体が動くのかと
じゃあ自分の思考はどうですかね
自分思うのままに管理できますかね
それは奇跡ですよ できればお釈迦様がこの自分と自分
弟子たちはそれほどすごいのかという場合
一つのケースありますよ
狙いは思いたいものを思うんや
いわゆる考えたもん 考えたいものを考える
考えたくないものを考えませんと
だから思考自体も自由自在である
好き勝手でできますか？できないでしょ
考えること自体も我々で自由にならないんですよ
肉体の心じゃところじゃないんです
だから自分でない肉体を持って
自分でない心を持って
私に子供がいるんだよと
あの 何 あの あの あの子の名前
石川 石何だったっけ？あのゴルフの
なんとか寮 え？石川 石川遼
だからまあそんな風な子供がいれば結構自慢するでしょうと思ったんですけどね
これは俺の息子やとかね
実際はそうなりません
自分の体さえも自分のものになってないんです
じゃあ石川君もまあもうゴルフで勝利を勝ち得たんだからね
それからどんな試合でも勝利だそうということはありえないでしょうね
これからはものすごく厳しく
あれこれと訓練しないと
練習しないと その立場は守れないんです
だからまあ そう頑張っている人は知ってますね
だからまぐれだと言えないように
これから頑張りますよと
そういうことで この何一つも自分の体さえも自分のものでないにも関わらず
この愚か者たちが何言ってるのかと
これは私の財産であると
自分のようにならないんですよ
私にはあれもある これもあると自慢したり
執着したりする しかし
自分の思い通りに何一つも動かないんです
振り返ってみると 自分が財産に振り回されていたこと
子供 家族に振り回されていたことに気づくでしょう
結局 私のお金だと思っちゃうと
お金に振り回されているんです
私の可愛い子供やと思ったっても
子供に 例えば石川遼君に振り回されます
あの両親はむちゃくちゃ
うちの子やと自慢したっても
結構うちの子の奴隷になるしかないでしょ
これからは まだ子供だから
いろんな外国なんか行ったりするとね
やっぱりついていかないと
だからそのお母さんにしたっても
また子供がいるのにね
もう手に手をかかることできなくなっちゃう
忙しくて 有名な子供のために
だから結局は自慢できるところじゃなくて
自分が振り回されてるだけなんですよ
財産に 家族に 子供たちに
振り回されるのはそれほど我慢できますけど
殺されますからね これってどういうことかと
まるっきり理解できないんですよ
親は子供に振り回されることはそんなにもう嫌だとは思わないんだけど
それでやがて殺すんだから
これはまあちょっとのところじゃないんです
自分の心 体さえも自分の思い通りにはならないものです
だから それでもってかっこいいとか自慢はできません
自分のものでないもので自慢できるならば
あの東京駅からちょこっと先に行ったら
このビルを私の このビルを私のとかね
言ってみて自慢してください
かっこいいや あんたにこんなにビルあるんでしょうかと
バカバカらしいでしょ
だから結局はもう何一つも自分のものになってないっていうこと
そういうことで 全然大富豪であることもかっこいいと決める手段にはもう基準にはなりません
こき使われることはかっこ悪いんです
だから財産に 家族に 子供に
いろんな人々にこき使われるだけだからね
立派な人がついてくると
これでかっこいいんじゃなくてかっこ悪いんです
ただの奴隷だからね はい
まあそれでまあ一応まあ我々一般的に気にするところ
もうちょっとあんまり気にしないかもしれませんだけど
これも一つのかっこいいと世間が決める基準なんですね
英雄であること 国のために戦って勝利を収める
国から勲章をもらい 国民に長く尊敬される
...というような生き方ができれば
まあおそらくかっこいいでしょうね
達することができる人は少ないんですけどね
格好はいいかもしれませんだけど
なかなかみんなは達しませんね
それでそれもみんな憧れますね
国の英雄になろうではないかとか
しかし お釈迦様の言葉は何でしょうかと
国のため戦って敵を殺して勝利を収めたら
まあ勲章はもらいますね
こういう経典があります
ヨーダジーを擦ったという
ヨーダっていうのは軍人です
アージーは職業です だから武士教という風に訳したんですけどね
スタンメタンバンテプッバカーナンアーチャリーパーチャリアナンヨーダジーヴァナンバサマナンバサマーナーナンヨーソーヨーダジーヴォサンガーメウッサハティワ
イマティタメーナンウッサハンタンワイマンタンパレーハナンティパリヤダペンティソーカーヤッサベーダパランマラナパラギターナンデーヴァナンサハヴェタンウパパッジャヤティイティ
イティバガヴァキマーハティという質問なんです
まあ現代人と違ってね
お釈迦様の時代でよく質問しますよ
人間は だからそれは知識レベルなんですよ
かなり知識が開発していた時期です
あの退化してなかったんで
だからもう質問を持っている
疑問いろいろ持っている
持っている疑問は堂々と出してみる
話し合ったりもするというね
で まあテレビなんかを見ているとも
いかに無駄話するのかっていうこと
それすごい自慢みたいですね
私もかなり才能だと思う
あれほど無駄話できるというね
かなり才能だなと思いますよ
まあ行くところは地獄に決まってますけどね
それでここでこの職業軍人がね
武士ですね お釈迦様に質問します
訳ありますけど まずちょこっと一般的な訳しておいて
まあ訳といっても私が訳したんだからね
まあ当てにはなりません
あの この武士系の人々がね
まあ子供たちも武士にするんですよ
だから自分の親が師匠で
おじさんがもっと上の師匠でとかね
代々このアーチャリアパーチャリアっていうのはそういうことで
アーチャリアっていうのは師匠のこと
パーチャリアっていうのは師匠の師匠
だからインドではこの武士はカースト一つですからね
一応王様たちは武士カーストの人々なんです
軍人なんです 王家の人々は
それで自分たちの先生たちは
師匠たちは 師匠の師匠たちは
もっと前の師匠たちはとかね
ずっと教えてくれるんだよと
武士道 そこで武士道な人は
武士が戦いに行って ウッサハティ
一生懸命頑張るんです
ワーヤマティっていうのはまた頑張ることなんですね
なかなかもう徹底的に頑張っちゃう
戦闘で ワーヤマティ タメーナンウッサハンタンワーヤマンタン
武士がむちゃくちゃ頑張るとどうなるんですかね
パレーハナンって敵対敵を殺すんですよ
パリアーダーペンってもう残酷な状態にするんです
家を燃やしたり いろんなことを強盗したり
財産を持っていったり
いろんなことをします
頑張ります 武士が そんなことで自分の職務をちゃんと全うすれば
ソーカーヤサベーダ 彼が死んでから
パランマラナ 死んでからパラジターナンという天界に生まれるんだよと
パラジタってパラっていうのは他人
ジタっていうのは勝ったという
他人に勝ったという いわゆる勝利者っていうことですね
勝利者の天国がありまして
その天国に生まれ変わりますよと師匠が言うんだから
若者たちはむちゃくちゃ言って
私は 10人殺したそうとかね
家は 10軒潰したそうとか自慢するんです
あんた 10軒ですかね
私は 13軒だよと 隣の武士がまた自慢したりして
そこで天国の立場も位も決めるとかね
メダルとかいっぱいもらいますからね
そこでお釈迦様に聞くんです
この先生たちの言葉について
お釈迦様はどんな意見でしょうかと
で ヨーダージーはガーミニーと
この人の名前なんですね
と 私は師匠 先師匠 先々師匠たちにこのように教わりました
武士は戦いにおいて努力する
その努力によって人々を殺したり
強盗したりする 彼が死後
その行いによって勝利天という天界に生まれる
この教えについて 釈尊の立場はどのようなものでしょうかと質問するのです
いわゆる世間の考えについて
ブッダのご意見を聞いているのです
釈尊は3回も返事することを断るのです
ノーコメントと 4回も質問されたので
このように答える お釈迦様っていうのは 1
回断って 2回も質問すると断って 3
回の質問すると答えるのです
まあ仏も3回ということですからね
戦いに挑む武士は心をこのように戒める
お釈迦様は言うのは この戦いに挑む武士の心はね
武士が心の訓練するんだからね
鉄砲の音を聞いただけで震えておしっこ漏らしちゃうんだったら武士にならんでしょ
だからもうかなり訓練しています
この人々は死ぬが良い
破壊した方が良い 亡くなった方が良い
いない方が良い だからどんな日本の軍隊であろうと
アメリカ軍隊であろうと
もう人間じゃないんだと
あいつらは とかね ただのターゲットだよと
英語で使う単語というのはターゲット
人間じゃないんです 生命でもなんでもないんです
単なる鉄砲を撃つ爆弾を落とすターゲットなんです
だから爆弾を落としたらターゲットエリミネイテッドと報告する
その無線で それから胸張っていくと
道路そばにある自爆爆弾爆破して
本人も天国に行くんです
だから武士がもう敵は人間で見ない
もう死んだ方がいい いない方がいい
地球からもう消えた方がいいと頭でマインドコントロールしているんです
お釈迦様それ言うんです
なんで武士はね そういうマインドコントロールしているんだよと
このように心を育てて
その通りに行動する それからマインドコントロールされた通りに戦います
人殺しする 彼が死後 敗北という名の地獄に落ちるんだと
あの勝利点じゃないんです
おそらくこの敗北天地獄と地獄はあるんだよ
そちらにいるんだといくらでも武士たちが
人殺しが良いとは邪見です
生命殺すのもダメですからね
生命は殺すことは良くないんです
だから人は殺した方がいいという考え方
邪見ですよ だから我々は考えがあって生きてるんですよ
何食べるか 何どんなところの全て思考なんですよ
例えばラーメンばっかし食って偏食になっちゃって体壊れたってても
その人はそういう思考を持ってるんです
ラーメンが美味しい 他の食べ物はおいしくないと
だから我々の生き方というのは思考そのものなの
だから思考を間違ったら全て終わり
間違い 足をつけたところで間違って転がったって大きな間違いじゃないんで
それで ちょっと痛いだけで終わりますからね
しかし 思考を間違っちゃうと
全人生が間違うんです
考え方おかしくなると
それで邪見と言うんですね
だから人殺した方がかっこいいと思う
この考え方は お釈迦様は邪見であると
邪見者は死後 地獄か畜生
畜生かどちらかに生まれるんでいる
天界にはもう行けません
人間にも戻れません 地獄か畜生なんですね
邪見は危ないんです それがお釈迦様の答えなんで
経典としてはちょっと長いんですけどね
まあかなり省略しています
そういうわけで まあ芸能人の話に入りますけど
あの世の中でいう この戦ってね
人を殺して これで天国っていうのはとてつもない邪見ですよ
明らかにこの神のために戦うことは聖戦という単語まであるでしょうに
どこまで無知かという
何の力もないくだらない人間が聖戦する
神を守るという この連中の頭どうなってるんですかね
神は偉大なるんだったら放っておけばいいでしょ
あいつに 全知全能の永遠不滅の神を守ってあげるんだから
もうもう 60年も生きていられないくだらない人間が
ちょっと食べ物当たっただけでも死ぬ人間が
神の神を守るという これ
キリスト教もイスラム教もどっちでも同じなんです
ヒンドゥー教も捨てたもんじゃないんです
ヒンドゥー教も結局は戦いの宗教にしちゃったんです
あれ インド文化ではもうアヒンサーと非暴力主義はもう広げていますから
どうしようもないんですよ
インド人というのはどうしてもとんでもない連中だからね
もう何考えてるかやっぱりわからないという
だからヒンドゥー教至上主義なんですけど
生きている場合はジャイナ教やら仏教から教えた生き方はしているんです
そうでなきゃ生きていられません
だってもう多言語で もう多民族で
もうものすごい世界一つですから
インド自体は だからお互いに仲良くしなきゃ生きていられません
だから非暴力主義とかね
まあいろいろ持ってますけど
自分が信仰する宗教が戦いの宗教なんです
あの現代ヒンドゥー教の聖典はバグアディータというテキストなんですね
日本訳もありますので
読んでみてください 趣旨は何なのかと
戦えってたった一行なんです
殺せと はい そういうことで
それは邪見なんです ブッダが言うのは
いかなる場合でも生命の命を奪うなかれと
そんな権利はないんだよと
自分には自分が生まれたんだから
自分ができるだけ長生きすることで十分ですよ
長生きしたい自分がなんで他の生命の命を奪うんですかね
はい そういうことで それも仏教はもうアウト
地獄に行く道がかっこいいわけじゃないんです